>>presenter: All right.
Well, good morning, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
Today's subject is a very momentous one.
It's a very powerful presentation we have
for you today.
Throughout the latter part of the 20th Century,
the idea of disarmament has been one of the
chief causes and the chief focal points of
world peace.
And today we have in our midst several heroes
who helped negotiate some of the landmark
agreements during the Cold War and in the
1980s and 90s.
The threat of nuclear terrorism still looms
today and these men are also working to help
control and contain that threat.
We're joined today by Professor Phil Taubman
of Stanford University for a discussion about
his book, which is entitled "The Partnership:
Five Cold Warriors and their Quest to Ban
the Bomb."
And we're honored today to have three of the
five warriors in our midst.
We have Secretary of State George Schultz,
Senator Sam Nunn, and Secretary of Defense
William Perry.
We'll have time for Q and A and the end, so
please feel free to use the microphones.
And for those of you who are in our six remote
offices dialing in, you can also find our
Google moderator link at “go/coldwarriors”.
So, without further ado, please join me in
welcoming everyone to Google.
Thanks.
[applause]
>>Phillip Taubman: Thank you all for coming.
And thank you Larry Page and Google for hosting
us today.
And my thanks to three of the five men who
are the subject of the book.
So, let me begin by setting the stage briefly
for a conversation that we'll have and we'll
have with you as well about nuclear weapons.
As was just noted, I think there is a sense,
a false sense, that when the Cold War ended
with the collapse of the Soviet Union and
the Warsaw Pact, that the threat of nuclear
attack also ended.
And that is a misunderstanding of our history,
unfortunately.
If you look at what's happened since the end
of the Cold War, I think President Obama captured
the paradox very effectively when he spoke
in Prague shortly after he was sworn-in as
President.
He gave a very eloquent and important speech
there in April of 2009 about nuclear issues.
And in that speech he said, "Today, the Cold
War has disappeared, but thousands of those
weapons have not.
In a strange turn of history, the threat of
global nuclear war has gone down, but the
risk of a nuclear attack has gone up."
What he's referring to, primarily, is the
risk of a nuclear 9/11, which is actually
as, far-fetched as it sounds, is a real possibility
at some point.
One that's hard to imagine, but one I think
that the country has to come to grips with
to try to prevent.
And when I was researching the book, [clears
throat] I spent some time with Bob Gates,
the Defense Secretary, who served in both
the Bush and Obama administrations.
And I asked him a question about what essentially
keeps him up at night.
And here's what he told me.
"If you were to ask most of the leaders of
the last Administration or the current Administration
what might keep them awake at night, it's
the prospect of a weapon or a nuclear material
falling into the hands of Al-Qaeda or some
other extremists.
And it doesn't have to be a weapon.
It could be nuclear material with regular
explosives and producing a degree of contamination
that would be catastrophic."
And finally, from the book, let me read you
a comment from Henry Kissinger, who was one
of the five men that I've chronicled in this
book.
And Kissinger is talking here about the reaction
if there were to be nuclear 9/11 or some other
kind of nuclear exchange.
And what we here at Google and in the Bay
Area, and frankly, around the world, what
people would be thinking at that point and
here's what he said: "Once nuclear weapons
are used, we will be driven to take global
measures to prevent it.
So, some of us have said 'Let's ask ourselves,
if we have to do it afterwards, why don't
we do it now?'"
The book and this discussion that we're gonna
have really focuses on the nuclear threats
that we continue to face today, which are
quite considerable.
Unbeknownst to most of us, during the Cold
War, the United States and Soviet Union distributed
research reactors to dozens of countries around
the world and provided those nations with
highly-enriched uranium to operate those research
reactors.
For years, this material was sitting around
in poorly-secured facilities, as I say, in
dozens of countries.
It's only been in recent years that the United
States and Russia had made a concerted effort
to try to secure this material, thanks in
large part to some legislation that Senator
Nunn offered with his Republican colleague,
Richard Lugar from Indiana--the so-called
Nunn-Lugar Legislation which you may have
heard of.
But the truth is, today there is tons of highly-enriched
uranium, which is the critical component of
a crude nuclear weapon.
There's still tons of it spread around dozens
of countries around the globe.
And it doesn't take much highly-enriched uranium.
Roughly 60 pounds to make a bomb.
And the technology for that kind of uranium
bomb is very straight-forward.
It requires some engineering skills, but it's
not beyond the capacity of a group of reasonably
sophisticated engineers and the kind of equipment
you can buy off the shelf to make a weapon.
And when the United States developed the first
nuclear weapons during the Manhattan Project
in World War II, the first bomb that we dropped
on Japan, the bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima,
was a uranium bomb.
And Robert Oppenheimer and his fellow scientists
who managed the Manhattan Project were so
confident of that technology, which essentially
takes two pieces of highly-enriched uranium--as
I say, you could do it with 60 pounds--and
brings them together at very high velocity.
And when the two pieces come together, you
get the criticality, the chain reaction that
releases this huge amount of energy.
That was so straight-forward.
They did not test that bomb before it was
dropped on Hiroshima.
The bomb that was dropped on Nagasaki was
a plutonium bomb.
Different, more complicated implosion technology
with plutonium.
That bomb was tested in New Mexico in 1945.
So, I think that just sets the stage here
for a discussion as was indicated when we
were introduced.
These three men have devoted a great deal
of time in recent years, time when they could
be enjoying themselves on the golf course,
to try to deal with this issue.
And, I think, we have to listen to them because
the three here and their two colleagues, Sid
Drell and Henry Kissinger, they're all men
who worked very hard to maintain America's
defenses during the Cold War.
They were stalwart cold warriors.
They were the builders, the maintainers, the
stewards of our huge nuclear arsenal during
the Cold War.
At its peak, the United States and Soviet
Union, believe it or not, had a grand total
of about 70 thousand nuclear warheads.
The number has come down.
It's now around 20 thousand, but 90 percent
of those are still under the control of the
United States and Russia.
These men know about nuclear weapons.
They know about the damage that can be produced
by a nuclear detonation in a city.
And they've devoted themselves to trying to
reduce these dangers.
President Obama has embraced a lot of the
policies that they've advocated, including
their aspirational critical goal of eventually
eliminating nuclear weapons.
So, if I may, Senator--.
>> Senator Shultz: Let me interject something
that builds on what you just said.
Sometimes people say, "Well, this sounds good,
but it's impossible.
You can't really get anywhere."
But you gave some numbers--70 thousand more
or less at the time of the Reykjavik meeting
between Reagan and Gorbachev and now.
Seventy to twenty.
It shows you yes, you can accomplish a lot.
It's not futile to be working on this.
You can get somewhere.
And that's an example.
>>Phillip Taubman: Good.
Good point, thank you.
Senator Nunn, as the author of Nunn-Lugar,
when you look back over the 20 years or so
since then, how would you rate what we've
been able to do in terms of preventing proliferation?
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Well, it's very hard to
quantify something that did not happen.
But after the Soviet Union broke up, I happened
to be there when they were having the debate
about breaking up.
And I got on an airplane and came back with
the determination to try to do something to
help the former Soviet Union, which was about
to be a controlled nuclear, not only nuclear,
but chemical, biological, not only weapons,
but materials.
'Cause huge, huge quantities of materials.
We joined up, as Phil said, Senator Lugar
and I, and passed the Nunn-Lugar legislation
in actually the late Fall of 1991.
>>Phillip Taubman: '91.
Right.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Right when the empire
was coming apart.
Very fortunately, within the next couple of
years, Bill Perry, who had helped envision
this idea, became Secretary of Defense.
And he and his team did a superb job of implementing
what was really more of an authorization than
it was an absolute mandate.
I score us pretty well on what's happened
in the last 20 years in terms of one of the
immediate outcomes that happened in the next
two or three years after legislation passed,
was that there were four countries that ended
up with nuclear weapons when the Soviet Union
broke up.
Russia, of course, Ukraine, Belarus, and Kazakhstan.
Three of those four countries gave up all
their nuclear weapons.
And if you take the arsenal of those three,
that basically exceeds the arsenal of China,
of Great Britain and France.
In fact, Ukraine alone had more weapons than
China, Great Britain and France.
So, I would say on that score, I would give
pretty high marks.
On the score of preventing nuclear materials
from leaking out to terrorist groups, you
don't know what you don't know.
So, no one can ever exclude the possibility
that some of that happened.
But I believe if terrorists groups had nuclear
materials in sufficient quantity, they would
have already attempted to make nuclear weapons.
So, perhaps we have been successful in that
regard.
But it's a continuing battle.
There's still a huge amount of nuclear material
in Russia.
Kazakhstan has some.
Kazakhstan has probably done better than anyone
else.
And just as, if you looked at the paper this
morning, you'll see that Ukraine as well as
Mexico in this Seoul Security Conference,
which is one of the real positive developments.
So, a follow-up to a conference that was held
in Washington two years ago with over 40 heads
of state, here in Seoul, Korea.
As we speak, over 50 heads of state are there.
And they're concentrating on nuclear material
protection.
Both Ukraine and Mexico have given up now
all their highly-enriched uranium.
So, they no longer have the materials that
would be used to make a bomb.
So, we're making progress.
Another sign of progress; during the George
W. Bush Administration, a program passed which
I think was enormously important, remains
important, called Global Threat Reduction
Initiative.
It was funding to help get nuclear material
back from places all over the world.
A few years ago, there were 40 countries that
had enough weapon-grade material to make a
bomb.
Today, there are 32.
And with Ukraine and Mexico, we can perhaps
say down to 30.
So, we're making progress.
And that GTRI program has been the basis with
Nunn-Lugar in working with Russia on getting
control of nuclear materials.
So, on a scale of one to ten in terms of material
protection, I think we've moved up the ladder
somewhere in the about seven neighborhood.
But it's a dynamic, continuing problem.
And it's not a static problem.
It's a dynamic problem.
India's continuing to make nuclear materials.
Great Britain is making nuclear materials.
Japan is making nuclear materials.
Not for the purposes necessarily in Japan
and Great Britain of making a bomb, but the
dilemma is it's the same material you use
for legitimate purposes and blend it up to
about four or five percent.
If you take it up to 20 percent enrichment,
it becomes weapons-usable.
If you take it up to 90 percent, you got yourself
a bomb.
It's the same technology.
But one encouraging thing in wrapping up,
this particular thought is that since 1991,
we have been working with Russia, Belarus,
Ukraine, Kazakhstan and other countries in
the former Soviet Union.
During the Bill Perry Administration as Secretary
of Defense, we made a deal with Ukraine to
basically have their nuclear materials sent
back to Russia that was coming out of those
weapons--the highly-enriched uranium--blend
it down in Russia and we bought it.
And we're still buying it.
It was a 20-year deal.
So, if you look at nuclear power in this country
today, 20 percent of our electricity is nuclear
power.
Fifty percent of the fuel going into those
nuclear power plants is coming from a blended-down
highly-enriched uranium that during the Cold
War was aimed at us.
So, by definition, ten percent, one out of
every ten light bulbs, one out of every ten
percent of any electricity in this country,
is coming from materials that were in nuclear
weapons aimed at us during the Cold War.
So, progress can be made, as George Schultz
said.
Progress is being made.
But there's a long way to go.
>>Phillip Taubman: Let me ask about progress
in a slightly different area, which is the
continued presence of large nuclear arsenals.
The United States has five thousand warheads
still under the New START Agreement with Russia.
We'll eventually come down to 15 hundred and
50 of those warheads being on active alert,
meaning the President can order them launched
on very short notice.
The rest are in reserve.
Russia has agreed to come down to that level,
too.
In South Korea today, Secretary Perry, President
Obama said that the United States has more
nuclear weapons than it needs.
If you were advising the President today or
were still Secretary of Defense, how many
nuclear weapons do we need on reasonably short
alert at this point?
>>Sec.
William Perry: I don't think we need any on
short alert.
We're not faced with that kind of threat today
as we thought we were during the Cold War.
How many we need to give us a level of deterrence
is to stop any other country who has nuclear
weapons from thinking they could attack us,
is measured in the hundreds, not in the thousands--a
few hundred, I would say, at the most.
Getting down to that number is a huge political
problem.
It has nothing to do with the need for deterrence.
It has to do with the fact that many people
in this country, maybe most people in this
country, would be reluctant for us to come
down to a few hundred nuclear weapons if Russia
still had a few thousand.
Whether that's a rational judgment or not,
that is a judgment, I think, which would be
made.
And so, other Administrations, this Administration,
the previous Administration that worked this
problem have always tried to work nuclear
disarmament in a bi-lateral way, that we come
down arm in arm with the Russians, either
through agreements or more typically, through
treaties.
So, the question then is if we did conclude
we come down to a few hundred, could we get
Russia to come down with us?
And the answer to that is probably not at
this time.
I just, matter of fact, just came back from
Russia.
I was there Friday and Saturday discussing
these issues.
The problem is that there's a dramatic asymmetry
between the United States' security position
and the Russian security position.
They believe that they are surrounded by instability,
unstable countries, and some hostile countries.
They believe correctly that their conventional
military forces are very weak.
And therefore, they lean on their nuclear
forces as an offset to that weakness.
And they did agree with us on the New START
Treaty to come down a modest decrease of what
they have, but they're gonna be very, very
hard to persuade to go down to levels of a
few hundred because they feel that their security
is very much at stake.
So, the short answer to your question is we
can certainly, we can maintain a high confident
level of deterrence with a few hundred, not
a few thousand, nuclear weapons.
And I doubt that we are gonna be able to get
there politically unless the Russians agree
to go with us.
And my present reading of the Russian view
is they're very unlikely to be able to make
major cuts.
They might make a small further token cut,
but they're not willing to make major cuts.
And besides, the weapons which we negotiate
in STAR Treaty was what we call and they call
strategic nuclear weapons.
They have probably four or five thousand tactical
nuclear weapons designed, as they see it,
to protect them from any problems, neighbors
on the Southern borders.
So, that is the asymmetry.
It's a real asymmetry.
And that's a real impediment in moving forward.
I'm not totally discouraged about the prospects,
but we have to recognize that that is a major
obstacle, that they look at the- their nuclear
weapons much differently than we look at them.
So, either we have to find a way of persuading
them that it's safe to come down, or we have
to be prepared to go down, laterally, to those
numbers only hoping that they will follow
in time.
>>Phillip Taubman: You know, it's--.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Let me underline something
that Bill said at the beginning of his remarks.
He said we don't need any deployed on short-term
alert.
Think of it.
We and Russia have a thousand or so nuclear
weapons pointed more or less at each other
on an alert system whereby if you have a warning
about a missile coming at you, you've got
only a matter of minutes to decide whether
to retaliate.
It is an insane arrangement.
I can't think of any conceivable dispute we
could have with Russia that warrants the risk
of a nuclear exchange.
And this kind of short-term alert status--Sam
has talked about this a lot--just doesn't
make any sense at all in this circumstance.
So, I should think that's something that could
be pointed to.
Early in his Administration, President Reagan
asked the Joint Chiefs of Staff to tell him
what would be the result if there were a Soviet
attack on us with nuclear weapons.
And they took their time.
And they came back with the answer, "Initial
casualties, 150 million."
And cascading casualties after that 'cause
we'd have no infrastructure left.
Would he retaliate?
Yes.
Result in Russia, or Soviet Union then, something
similar.
So he always said, "What's so good about maintaining
the peace by inability to wipe each other
out?"
What have you won if you both wiped out?
But the system of the short-term trigger points
still is there.
And it's just insanity.
>>Phillip Taubman: So, Secretary Schultz is
the only person in this room who actually
sat at a bargaining table with the leader
of the Soviet Union and discussed eliminating
nuclear weapons entirely.
That was at the Reykjavik Summit between Mikhail
Gorbachev and Ronald Reagan in Iceland in
1986.
You now, along with your colleagues, have
moved the discussion about eliminating nuclear
weapons back into a position where it's being
seriously considered and discussed.
How would we achieve that goal, Secretary
Schultz?
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Well, we're working at
it.
And attitudes have changed.
I remember when we came back from the Reykjavik
Meeting, I was virtually summoned to the British
Ambassador's residence to meet with Margaret
Thatcher, who came over.
She used to carry a little stiff handbag.
And I learned that there was a verb in the
British language, "to be handbagged."
[laughter]
>>Phillip Taubman: Is that in the movie, "The
Iron Woman?"
[laughs]
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: I don't know.
But I got handbagged.
"George, how could you sit there and let the
President agree to get rid of nuclear weapons?"
"But Margaret, he's the President."
"Yes, but you're supposed to be the one with
his feet on the ground."
"But Margaret, I agree, but--."
[laughter]
And her reaction was fairly typical around
Washington and elsewhere that this was the
kind of result you expect when two leaders
get loose on their bureaucracies and talk
about what's on their minds.
But now, after we issued our first Op-Ed about
five years ago, the atmosphere is entirely
different.
I don't mean that everybody's agreeing with
us, but there's much more willingness to talk
about it.
And in many cases, to join us in an effort
to get rid of nuclear weapons.
So, I think that the whole atmosphere has
changed and changed for the better.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Fourteen countries, George,
to your point where former Secretaries of
State or Defense or top officials have basically
written and endorsed our position on this,
which we call "The Vision and the Steps."
The vision being a world without nuclear weapons.
The steps, all the hard things you have to
do to get there.
Everybody knows you have to get there step-by-step.
But nevertheless, we've had about 14 countries
that have now endorsed that.
And there are networks, both in Asia and in
Europe, that are working on this issue now.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Actually, let me point
out.
There's a very interesting interaction between
the vision and the steps.
In fact, if you have a vision of where you
want to go, what does it do to you?
It calls you to say, "How do I get there?"
Then, you start thinking of things that are
doable that you could do.
And the more you develop those, the more the
vision takes on the air of reality.
And the interesting thing about it is at each
step that we have recommended, it's taken.
For example, if this effort that's going on
now in Korea, as it becomes more successful
getting control of this material, as that
is done, it makes the world safer, as Sam
has developed earlier.
So, there's a nice interaction between having
a goal and the steps you need to get there.
And all the steps would be positive.
Excuse me, sir.
>>Phillip Taubman: No, no.
That's fine.
Let's go to questions in a minute.
I just was gonna note that the book actually
opens with a scene at the United Nations.
In 2009, the Security Council met--you may
remember this--it was the 50 nations on the
Security Council were represented by the heads
of state from each of the nations and the
Chair that day was President Obama.
And at that session, I think Secretaries Schultz
and Perry and Senator Nunn and Henry Kissinger
were actually in the Security Council chamber
that day, watching the discussion.
And at the end of the meeting, the Security
Council voted unanimously to embrace the goal
of eliminating nuclear weapons and to call
for the kinds of restraints that had been
advocated by the gentlemen here.
So, let's begin with some questions here in
Mountain View.
And I know there are people at other Google
locations.
If you send your questions, we'll field some
of those as well.
So, please.
>>male #1: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
I have two questions.
First, what's the best response that we should
take for the Iranian proliferation threat?
And I forgot the second one.
>>Phillip Taubman: OK.
I think that might be a good one for Secretary--
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: You remind me of Governor
Perry.
[laughter]
>>Senator Sam Nunn: I learned in politics
a long time ago, when you're gonna say something
about numbers, don't ever use the number.
Say, "I have a few questions today."
You can stop at two or three or four, nobody
knows.
[laughter]
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: I think on the Iranian
issue, we're missing a very important thing
that we should have been doing and could do
now that would give our diplomacy more bite.
One of the things you learn when you try to
do diplomacy is that if you have no strength
when you go to the bargaining table, you're
gonna get your head handed to you.
You've gotta bring strength.
Now, Iran has been conducting what is virtually
acts of war for a long time by their support
for Osama, by their terrorist acts around
the world, by things that they are doing.
This recent apprehension of somebody who was
out to assassinate on US soil a Saudi ambassador
and so on.
And we don't do anything about those types
of things.
And I think we need to hit them back.
I'll give an example.
In the 1980s, mid-1980s, Iranians started
to play around with Kuwaiti shipping.
So, we re-flagged the ships to our flag so
that we could guard them.
And while the President of Iran was in the
United Nations, saying the last thing in the
world Iran would do would put a mine in the
Persian Gulf, our Navy was taking pictures
of them doing it.
So, we boarded the ship, took off the sailors
and took off some mines for evidence, sank
the ship, took the sailors to Dubai and said,
"Come and get your sailors and cut it out."
Now that was communication.
And I think we need some of that hard reaction
back to these provocations that Iran is constantly
doing.
>>male #1: My second question was given that
we're not going to be able to get rid of nuclear
weapons today, unfortunately, what are your
thoughts on the aging of the nuclear arsenal
and the Reliable Replacement Warhead Program?
>>Sec.
William Perry: What was that question?
>>Phillip Taubman: It was about the aging
arsenal and the Reliable Warhead program.
Bill, why don't you field that one?
>>Sec.
William Perry: We haven't tested a bomb or
built a new bomb for several decades now.
And so, this deterrence, which we have today,
comes whether we have a hundred or a thousand
or two thousand.
It comes from weapons which are 30, 40 years
old and being carried by missiles which are
almost as old.
So, the question is: “How do we maintain
confidence in our arsenal under those conditions?”
We have, at the laboratories, something which
actually created when I was Secretary of Defense
back in 1996, I believe it was, called the
Stockpile Stewardship Program, in which we
used the most advanced technology, the most
advanced computers for checking out the reliability
of our nuclear weapons and taking corrective
actions when they need to be taken.
This program has been enormously successful
and I have great confidence that as far as
I can assess, our nuclear stockpile will remain
reliable without testing, without building
new weapons, for decades to come.
I hope that by that time we have had some
success in the endeavor we’re on, so that
the question of the reliability of the stockpile
goes away because we don't have stockpiles.
But in any event, with high confidence I can
say that we can maintain this reliability
of our present stockpile for decades into
the future.
And we're doing it because of very, very sophisticated,
very advanced technology including using the
most powerful computers in the world to simulate
what's going on.
One other comment on that.
We have just a few miles from here at Lawrence
Livermore Laboratory, a program called the
National Ignition Facility.
The goal of that facility is to create fusion
by having almost 200 very high-powered lasers
direct their energy in one very, very small
spot.
It causes fusion to take place, which recreates
the energy, the temperature of the sun--higher
than the sun, actually.
So, what they're doing is basically, in the
laboratory, creating the same conditions we
would have when a nuclear bomb goes off.
So, we will be able to simulate a nuclear
bomb with amazing fidelity in just a few years
in the future.
We're already doing a pretty good job of it.
Short answer to your question, several decades
into the future, high confidence because of
the highly qualified scientists we have in
our laboratories and highly sophisticated
computers they use, all of which lead to very
high fidelity simulation, which then can be
used to correct any problems that are disclosed.
>>Phillip Taubman: Please.
>>male #2: Thank you for honoring us with
your presence.
I have several questions.
>>Phillip Taubman: Speak up a little bit,
please.
>>male #2: I have several questions.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Just one at a time.
>>male #2: The first one is can you help me
understand the set--.
Mr. Perry, I believe you said Russia has a
lot of instability around itself and therefore,
needs to maintain a higher count of nuclear
warheads.
But at the same time, are they not the ones
who are exporting nuclear technology to Iran?
And how does that make them more stable?
And then, my second question is we seem to
be--.
I mean, there's a lot of reliance in nuclear
energy on the uranium fuel cycle, whereas
we know and we have developed technology in
the United States in the '60s around the thorium
nuclear cycle, which has if not zero, a much
smaller amount of fission by-products.
Is anybody looking at actually offering the
world who needs energy?
You know, like, perhaps, a less dangerous
solution?
>>Phillip Taubman: William, do you want to
talk first about Russia's position?
>>Sec.
William Perry: Let me ask Sam to cover that
second point, which I think is the key point.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: We were frustrated for
a number of years because Russia was, as you
said, furnishing technology and so forth for
the Bashir reactor in Iran.
They finally came around to a position after
a lot of discussion to taking back all the
fuel from that.
So, there is a closed loop here now and that's
acceptable because Iran has a right for nuclear
power, nuclear resources and so forth.
Where Iran is going wrong is they've been
cheating.
They have not fulfilled their non-proliferation
objectives.
They have the right to enrich.
So, Russia is doing better on that count.
Where Russia has not been nearly as forthcoming,
and China, as we would like is on tightening
the screws on sanctions.
There are a couple of--.
Iran is basically a dark cloud, but a couple
of little light spots on it.
One is that the Iranian economy is now--and
this is unfortunate for the Iranian people,
but it's better than conflict--they are suffering
basically.
Their currency has gone down very appreciably,
so sanctions are beginning to really squeeze.
And more and more countries are joining in
those, exceptions Russia and China.
But even in there, they will be negotiating
a lower oil price because the Europeans are
cutting off their oil purchase.
So, the bright, one little bright spot is
the economy is beginning to pinch.
And I think we may see a little more forthcoming
from the Iranians--hopefully.
The second one is, and this is one, I think,
we need to be very careful about, is certainly
one that I don't put complete faith in, but
the Ayatollah keep saying that developing
a nuclear weapon or possessing a nuclear weapon
would be a sin.
I think there ought to be some moral engagement,
not by our government necessarily, but by
the Vatican and other religious leaders.
I think we need to engage them on a religious
basis.
Now, do I believe that based on what the Iranian
government is doing?
No.
I don't.
But I do think it's a place for the Iranians
to land if they ever back down without losing
face.
So, those are the two very tiny bright spots
that I would point out.
But let me defer to Bill on the alternative
there.
>>Sec.
William Perry: I believe the Russians are
fully convinced that nuclear proliferation
poses a threat, not just the United States,
but to them as well.
In fact, if anything, they're probably in
greater danger of a nuclear attack in their
country then we are in the United States.
And I think they understand that.
So, by and large, are they doing the things
they need to do in this field.
Unfortunately, some of the things they need
to do are adverse to their economic interests.
And so, there's a tension there that some
groups to the Russian government are pushing
their, including their atomic energy, which
is called Russ Atom, is more interested in
selling reactors than they are in the proliferation
issue.
But the Russian government, at the highest
level, is fully aware of the proliferation
danger and has taken some positive actions
to deal with it.
>>Phillip Taubman: There was a question--.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: One thing we could do in
the nego--.
There's now a negotiation taking place and
I don't see why we don't table a proposition
like this.
You say that you're enriching uranium for
peaceful purposes.
You are enriching a volume of uranium that
far exceeds anything you might possibly need
in Iran.
Therefore, you must be doing it in anticipation
of selling it into the international market.
Welcome.
Let's set up an arrangement whereby we have
supervision of plants and we give you access
to the international market and put that proposition
out there.
>>Phillip Taubman: There was a question coming
in from another location about applying new
technologies to nuclear reactors including
the use of thorium.
Bill, is there some reactor technology revolution
around the corner that would help us with
this fuel cycle security issues and also safety
issues of reactors?
>>Sec.
William Perry: You can certainly build new
reactors with much safer technology than any
of the reactors certainly exist.
And we ought to be doing that as we get new
reactors.
One candidate is something called a small
modular reactor, which is now being understudied
at our Department of Energy.
But whatever we do in that regard, there's
tons and tons of high-energy uranium out there.
There are countries all over the world using
reactors.
They're going to be using them ten, 20, 30
years into the future.
So, that high energy uranium is going to be
out there.
The technology for making highly enriched
uranium is going to be out there.
So, even if we pivot to new technologies for
the new reactors, we'll have for decades a
huge problem with the reactors that currently
exist, which have another 20, 30 years lifetime
in them and the uranium that they use.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: We're also trying our
best to get countries around the globe and
private sector to use low-enriched uranium
instead of high-enriched uranium.
In some cases, that's a very expensive process
that's gonna take a long time.
That's beginning to happen, slowly, not quite
surely.
>>Phillip Taubman: Please.
>>male #3: Hi.
Getting back to the Middle East, Israel has
argued that they need to attack Iran in a
year or so, or else it's too late.
Obama seems to temper them, but voices strong
support for Israel.
I just was curious about your, anybody's analysis
of the situation.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Well, the Israelis understandably
hear the Iranians say they wanna wipe you
out five times a day.
If they have a nuclear weapon on the end of
the missile, they could do it.
So, you believe them.
And just when it becomes impossible to really
stop their nuclear weapon program via military
attack, is a question mark.
And how good our intelligence is on this is
a question mark.
The Israelis obviously feel it a lot more
than anybody else because they're closer and
more threatened.
So, I think it's a very difficult issue for
them.
President Obama did say in the last set of
meetings something very significant I thought.
He said, "We are not talking about containing
a nuclear-armed Iran.
We're talking about not allowing it to happen."
That's a big conceptual statement.
And just where it takes him in terms of timing,
I have no idea.
>>Sec.
William Perry: Let me add something to that.
George is explaining it quite correctly why
the Israelis are concerned, deeply concerned.
In an existential way, they're concerned about
an Iranian nuclear bomb.
And they have, indeed, drawn up a plan for
military attack.
The question is would they press the button
and execute that plan.
They understand as well as we understand that
even if that attack succeeds, there would
be a whole host of unintended consequences.
And all of those unintended consequences are
bad.
So, they do not want to have to press that
button.
The way we could help them make the decision
not to press the button, not to conduct that
attack, is be more successful with our diplomacy.
It has to be, as George has indicated, coercive
diplomacy.
It has to get the Iranians attention.
It has to--.
And that means being much more successful
on sanctions.
Sanctions ordinarily are not effective.
Iran, on the other hand, is highly susceptible
to financial sanctions--cutting off their
access to international banks and so on.
And to the extent they have been applied already,
they have really gotten their attention.
But it takes fuller cooperation from Russia
and fuller cooperation from China in order
to make those completely effective.
So, part of our diplomacy is directed to Iran,
but another part of our diplomacy needs to
be directed to Russia and China to get them
fully behind those sanctions.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Let me add one other point
here.
I think military and use of force would be
the last resort, but it is still on the table.
Certainly it's on the table with Israel.
It's on the table explicitly by the President
of the United States.
I think Iranians need to understand that.
I think the other thing the Iranians need
to understand and I think we also have to
understand it, is it's not, in my view, just
a matter of taking out a few nuclear sites.
If you're gonna fly over there, you wanna
take out the air defense systems.
And if you were in Israel, you wanna take
out the offensive systems that could be used
in retaliation.
And the Iranians, it seems to me, are not
very wise in identifying the Persian Gulf
as something they may target to close because
certainly would make military targeters, if
not political leaders, think that we may need
to take out the Navy and parts of the Air
Force.
So, this is not two or three planes flying
over Iran and dropping a few bombs and taking
out a site or two.
The number of sites is multiple.
I do not think that would stop the Iranians
in the long term.
It would set them back for a while.
But they need to understand the seriousness
of what they're doing here.
And I think we need to all understand this
does have, as Senator Perry said, certainly
a lot of consequences if we take it.
It's not gonna be a one shot proposition.
It's gonna go on some time.
The other part of the debate that goes back
and forth is whether you can really deter
the Iranians if they get a weapon.
And you can argue that all day long, but you're
in Israel and you hear the threats being made
over and over again, then you would not put
much comfort in the fact that you might be
able to deter them with your own capability
of retaliation.
So, that argument, it seems to me, is not
very definitive.
The final point I would make is it's not just
a matter of deterring the Iranians.
Even if you assume you could deter the Iranians,
if the Iranians get nuclear weapons, it's
gonna set off a chain in the Middle East.
I don't know how long it would take, but there's
certainly inevitably gonna be a number of
other countries that have nuclear weapons.
The more we have of nuclear weapons, nuclear
programs, enrichment, as we've already discussed,
the more danger we have of--even if they're
not used by a nation--they could be used by
a terrorist group that doesn't have a return
address if they get the material.
It increases the likelihood of that.
So, this is not simply about deterrence.
It's also a matter at the heart of proliferation.
>>Phillip Taubman: So, there are two questions
from remote locations that are very similar.
I'll read you the one that's currently visible.
"How could we best make the average citizens
aware of the current threat of the need for
disarmament?
It seems that the need is clear upon investigation,
but how do we take this message to the masses?"
Or, as the other questioner said, "How do
we convey this and get ordinary citizens to
do something about this?"
And I think Senator Nunn, you've been leading
this effort through an organization that he
co-chairs called the "Nuclear Threat Initiative."
He's been working on this for many years.
How you do get people who work at Google,
in the Bay Area, around the world, the average
citizens who don't wake up in the morning
thinking about nuclear threats, how do we
get people to take this matter seriously?
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Well, I would--.
There are a number of things, but let me just
emphasize one and defer to George and Bill
on this.
But we did make a movie.
And we called it "The Nuclear Tipping Point."
And you can get that movie.
We give it away free.
George and Bill and Henry and I, we are on
the movie.
It's more of a documentary.
It lasts about 30 or 40 minutes.
It's called "The Nuclear Tipping Point."
You can get it at nuclear tipping point dot
org, or you can go to our website called nti.org,
or dot-com.
It works either way.
So, that's one way because it's an informative
movie.
It tells you where we're coming from.
It tells you not only about the vision, but
about all the hard steps we have to take to
get there.
The other thing is understanding that the
United States has a real stake in the whole
global security and regional conflict.
My view of it is that we're not talking about
a world without nuclear weapons.
Today's world, simply subtract any nuclear
weapons.
You gotta change a lot of things in the world.
We talked already about the Middle East.
We've talked about the former Soviet Union
and Russia and their feeling that they depend
on nuclear weapons.
That's another whole area.
We gotta talk about North Korea, Northeast
Asia.
There are a lot of things that have to be
done.
And perhaps the most dangerous of all is India
and Pakistan 'cause these are two heavily
armed nuclear countries that have been to
war several times.
So, all of those things have to be part of
public awareness, but I would say directly
take a look at that movie and I think it'll
be pretty informative.
>>Sec.
William Perry: Let me build on what Sam was
just saying.
We have had, I think, pretty good success--the
small group of us--in getting the message
across to the political elite and to the older
generation.
What we're trying--.
But that doesn't, it's not adequate in dealing
with the problem.
We need to get across to the generation we
see here.
You may notice the people sitting in this
room don't look much like us.
[laughter]
We're about two generations separate.
We created the problem, I guess, by building
these nuclear weapons in the first place.
Your generation has to be responsible solving
them.
But I teach a class at Stanford.
And I try to bring this message across to
students there because I want them to take
it out.
Just think.
If each person at Google, if even 20 percent
of the Google people, once they get the film
that Sam was talking about—The Nuclear Tipping
Point--.
>>Phillip Taubman: Once they read the book.
>>Sec.
William Perry: Or read the book.
But whatever you do yourself, what I'm suggesting
is call together, have a meeting with your
friends.
Invite ten of your friends to your home.
Show them the movie.
Show them the book and have a discussion among
yourself.
And then if each of, two or three of those
ten people would do the same thing we start
a multiplicative effect here going on and
start getting it out to hundreds of thousands,
to millions of people instead of hundreds
of people.
So that's the sort of thing that needs to
be done.
And it's really up to your generation to do
it, which is why we're sitting here at Google
talking to you.
We're trying to get you interested not in
listening to this and becoming convinced yourself,
but in doing something about it.
And the first thing that has to be done is
getting the message out because until the
message is out, there will not be enough political
will in the US Congress and again in another
provenance in the world to really take the
action needed.
You cannot take that action, but can take
the action of getting the message out.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Phillip Taubman, I would
imagine--.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Here's an example of something
we're doing.
This subject has great resonance with religious
leaders.
I mean, they look at it and said, "Where is
it written that a human being should have
the ability to press a button and kill a million
people?"
What is this, anyway?
Where's the morality?
So, we had an inquiry from Evangelicals a
few years ago.
Said, "We wanna come to Hoover and hear what's
going on."
So, they came.
We sent them some reading material.
About 35 came.
Bill talked with them.
I talked with them.
They spent a day talking about it.
And they have since issued some very strong
statements on behalf of the Evangelicals.
Then there are the Catholic Bishops, who had
made very strong statements on this.
And then there's a really terrific guy here
in San Francisco named Bill Swing.
He's a retired Episcopal Bishop of California.
And he started something called United Religion
Initiative.
He has millions of people all over the world
from all religions.
And the idea is let's pick a few subjects
on which we might agree and work on them.
And he has picked this subject as one of his
subjects.
So, these are ways of--.
We're always seeking ways to get this message
out, as it says.
And to get people to be concerned with the
notion that if they are, then in the end,
that's gonna get reflected in political decision-making.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Let me ask a question
of Phillip.
You've been an outstanding journalist for
many years.
You could've written a book on many, many
subjects.
What was the motivation for writing this book
at this time for you?
>>Phillip Taubman: I think the motivation
began in 1988.
I was the Moscow Bureau Chief of the New York
Times.
And for the first time in the history of the
Cold War, the Soviet Union invited a group
of American scientists to come and witness
a nuclear test--underground nuclear test--at
the Soviet test site in Kazakhstan.
And I was invited to go along to write about
it.
And when you are present at a nuclear test,
even an underground nuclear test, it leaves
a lasting impression.
The bomb went off about a half a mile below
the Earth's surface.
And then I stood there [clears throat] and
watched as a shock wave rippled across the
Kazakhstan Steppe.
It looked like a tsunami, except it was the
earth was moving.
And it literally rippled across for a mile
and a half until it hit the site where I was
standing with these scientists.
It almost knocked us over.
And that is where the motivation to write
this book began.
And then, I went to Hiroshima later.
I saw what's left there of the damage caused
by our attack on Hiroshima.
I went to Los Alamos to try to understand
the origins of the bomb.
And all of this, as someone who covered national
security affairs during the Cold War, realizing
the degree of danger that we had of a nuclear
conflagration with the Soviet Union.
I sort of woke up again in 2007 and ‘08,
after this article came out that the four
men wrote.
And I recalled all of these things that I
just cited to you and I said, "There's a book
here that should be written.
And it should be written because we need to
get people around the world to understand
the threat that exists and to try to do something
about it."
So, let's see.
We're towards the end of our time frame here.
So, we'll do--I apologize--one more question.
Or two.
Let's do two here in Mountain View and then
we'll call it a day.
Thank you.
>>male #4: So, I'll make a quick two-part
question.
The first is about unknown and untracked threats.
>>Sec.
William Perry: Can't hear you.
>>male #4: The first one is about unknown
or untracked threats.
You've talked about reduction in strategic
stockpiles.
Do we know enough about what was disseminated
[ inaudible ] network across the world?
Is that material tracked or bounded?
And the second part of that question, somewhat
related, is there enough engagement from leaders
in previous and current US Administrations
to prevent an India-Pakistan nuclear exchange
following a likely terrorist strike?
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Let me tackle the last
one.
It's a really important.
And about when was it?
Six months ago, Bill and I convened a group
of Indian and Pakistani former foreign ministers,
former generals and so on, who still have
some influence in their governments.
And we sat at our conference room at Hoover
for two days and discussed what they, how
they might compose themselves better.
They did produce a very impressive set of
confidence-building measures in the nuclear
area that they all signed on to and presented
to their governments.
Maybe more important, we talked about the
opportunities for economic advancement that
they're missing by virtue of the tension that's
present.
I tried to get that up there.
But I would say at the same time, I think
Bill, on side conversations with some of the
Pakistani generals, you say, "Well, what's
worrying you the most?"
And they all say, "A nuclear war."
Because there are all these people who have
a stake in India-Pakistan enmity.
That somebody could go and do another Mumbai.
And probably the Indians would not be able
to be as restrained as they were after the
first Mumbai.
And that could lead to an invasion which could
lead to the start of a nuclear exchange.
So, you gotta be really worried about that.
That's why I just would underline what Sam
said a minute ago, that it's not the present
world without nuclear weapons.
You gotta work at these problem areas and
see if there isn't something that can be done
to settle them down.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Let me add one point.
I agree with everything George said on it,
but there was an American Scientific magazine
a year or so ago that just used supercomputers
to play the hypothetical scenario of a hundred
weapons going one off between India and Pakistan.
And they projected, and even if you divide
this by half or a quarter, it still tells
you the story that a couple hundred million
people would be killed if a hundred weapons
went off between the two.
But over the next five years, six years, there
would be a billion people or more that would
starve to death because of the cooling effect
on the atmosphere.
So, this is not simply a sovereign problem.
This is much bigger.
It's a global problem.
We have the capacity of using nuclear energy
to really greatly better mankind or we have
the capacity to destroy God's Universe.
And I think that all of us have a stake in
that all over the world.
Our network was a bazaar, an arms bazaar.
And I don't think we've had enough access
to know how extensive it was.
We know a lot, but not enough.
>>Phillip Taubman: Right.
>>Male #4: Thank you.
>>Phillip Taubman: OK.
Last question.
Thank you.
>>male #5: So, nuclear energy has potential
to change the world in terms of carbon dioxide
reduction, but a lot of the technologies involve
uranium or plutonium and the fuel cycle in
some way.
If somebody comes out and invents a new nuclear
power technology that does not require uranium,
plutonium, or any of those materials in the
fuel cycle, so that they're--.
You know, in a couple years, there's absolutely
no economic reason to refine uranium or plutonium.
Does that give you a tool in the arms and
proliferation reduction?
In other words, there should be no reason
anybody is refining any volume whatsoever
of those fuels.
>>Sec.
George P. Schultz: Obviously, the answer is
yes.
On the other hand, as Bill pointed out, there
are lots of nuclear power plants in operation
and under construction right now, mostly in
China and India, but a couple in Sam's state
of Georgia.
And they're going to going on for quite a
while.
So,--.
>>Male #5: Do we have enough bomb pits to
keep those busy for a while?
[Sec.
George P. Schultz laughs]
>>Senator Sam Nunn: So, we've got enough nuclear
material out there.
I agree.
It would be a real breakthrough.
I mean, hopefully we can get to that.
But there's enough nuclear material out there
to make 40, 50 thousand nuclear weapons.
And so, your generation is gonna have continuing
challenges.
This is a dynamic, continuing problem, but
we can make a lot of progress.
>>male #5: Thank you.
>>Phillip Taubman: Great.
Well, thank you all and as Bill Perry has
put it, "I hope from this discussion some
of you will think seriously about these issues
and think about how you might get involved
in trying to deal with them because it's a
worldwide problem and the last thing we wanna
have happen is wake up some day and discover
that New York or Washington or London or Paris,
or whatever city has been destroyed by a nuclear
weapon."
Thank you very much for coming.
>>Senator Sam Nunn: Just one final word.
You can't imagine how hard it is to take this
subject and write a book about it.
That is really a challenge.
Phillip has done a great job.
So, his book is I think very well worth reading.
And I'm not getting any part of the commission.
[laughter]
[applause]